and let's fast forward 2013 14 15 when
you talk about the world using this as
your payment using this as your wallet
going to a bar and getting in because
you've got this this is big stakes and
big big money on the line the company
Amazon Facebook Google Apple that wins
the phone War over the next half decade
will be the biggest company in the
world and what happens when we all start
paying with
it because they sure do in Japan and
South Korea I'm not predicting the
future I'm just going to tell you what's
about to happen I don't know if has
anybody here paid with with a Starbucks
app yet raise your hand just curious how
many you know 20 10 people in here
already paid for something with their
cell phone I think every person in this
room will pay for something with their
cell phone in 36 to 48 months it's going
to
happen I love love
you hey